nein das ist ein kampf zwischen den
vielen menschen die an den frieden
glauben und jenen wenigen die sich den
krieg wünschen
es ist ein kampf zwischen zivilisation
und barbarei und diesen kampf dann
werden wir mit aller entschlossenheit
führen so betroffen uns die ereignisse
der gestrigen nacht machen so dankbar
dürfen wir auch sein für die unfassbare
solidarität die in unserem land herrscht
unser dank gilt den sicherheitskräften
die nach wie vor im einsatz sind für die
sicherheit der bevölkerung in unserem
land unser dank gilt den rettungskräften
die teilweise ihr leben riskiert haben
um anderen menschen zu helfen unser dank
gilt aber auch allen menschen die
gestern durch mut und zivilcourage sich
ausgezeichnet haben indem sie verwundete
versorgt haben oder auch indem sie
videos aufgenommen haben und die später
auf die plattform der polizei
hochgeladen haben und so einen
wertvollen beitrag in der
ermittlungsarbeit leisten und unser dank
das möchte ich auch an dieser stelle
erwähnen gilt all unseren
internationalen partnern die noch
gestern nacht ihre solidarität zum
ausdruck gebracht haben von emanuel ag
aus frankreich bis in die anderen aus
neuseeland
unzählige unserer europäischen und
internationalen partner haben mir und
somit uns noch gestern nacht persönlich
ihre solidarität ausgesprochen und uns
jegliche unterstützung zugesagt
wir werden mit unseren internationalen
partnern den kampf gegen den extremismus
und den terrorismus gemeinsam führen
geeint durch rechtsstaatlichkeit unsere
liberale demokratie und unsere
grundwerte stehen wir seite an seite in
frieden und sicherheit zu verteidigen
und zwar nicht nur in österreich sondern
auch in europa und der ganzen welt
ich habe den innenminister gebeten mit
allen verfügbaren kräften an der
aufklärung dieses anschlags zu arbeiten
das österreichische bundesheer hat in
der zwischenzeit den objektschutz in
wien vollständig übernommen damit die
polizei alle ihre kräfte für die
ermittlungsarbeit bündeln kann
wir haben darüber hinaus den nationalen
sicherheitsrat einberufen um mit allen
relevanten stellen der republik die
aktuelle lage und die nächsten schritte
zu besprechen und gemeinsam mit dem
bundespräsidenten den vertretern der
parlamentsparteien dem bürgermeister und
dem vize kanzler werden wir heute auch
den opfern des anschlags gemeinsam
gedenken und ich lade sie ein sehr
geehrte damen und herren um 12 uhr an
einer österreichweiten gedenkt minute
für die opfer des gestrigen anschlags
dabei zu sein
wir werden die opfer des gestrigen
abends niemals vergessen und wir werden
gemeinsam entschlossen unsere grundwerte
verteidigen
vielen dank
die hatte fritz ja danke schön danke ich
den fernseher